today's episode is brought to you by
t-mobile America's best unlimited
network
hey screen junkies welcome back to
another episode of honest trailer
commentaries today we are talking about
the one you hopefully just watched this
is the wrong place to watch it you watch
this after you watch stranger things yes
season 1 1 this was a something we
planned on releasing a little earlier
yeah when the season 2 came out yet and
a series of events has led it to being
released today yes and you know
sometimes sometimes you have plans and
and things get promised and then you
can't do those things in the timeline
that you thought you could but you still
have to do make the things that said
even we've all seen season 2 by now yeah
yes I don't think it changed the
dynamics or the things we had to say in
too drastic of a way no we just added a
few little references we couldn't have
done season 2 anyway yeah because we
don't have the footage like luckily
stranger things kind of at the last
minute came out with footage that we
could legally use yeah you know you can
purchase and buy and we were already
having that struggle so we couldn't have
done so yeah this is something that we
do right up top in the trailer and just
if this is one of your first times here
we're gonna watch trailer we're gonna
comment on it and then you will see
deleted scenes of the stuff we cut out
and there's actually quite a bit for
this one quite a bit at the end but we
say up front that we can't show clips
from season two because not out on
blu-ray and that is why we don't do
movies before they come out so if you're
the person in the comments who says why
haven't you done because it's not out
and we will legally get literally be
criminals we would be pirates if we did
thor ragnarok before he came out to
purchase yeah and these Netflix things
they don't come out on DVD for years
ever yeah or ever we may never get to do
defenders daredevils we have an ax
daredevil we haven't done defenders yeah
we got you got to be able to purchase
the Ozarks
we may never do yeah the ranch yeah know
what to do that one why mine hunters was
watching that mine hunter I hear it's
good it's fine yeah it's it's like ASMR
television like a very calm after serial
killers no
no it's just quiet conversations about
serial killers great Joe I always wanted
to do these the first Netflix original
Lillehammer and I'm very upset that
[Laughter]
Netflix is artless early one before it
really got its footage figured it out
that's what you guys are watching for
our artless talk geez cut HBO and
Netflix original series there anything
you guys want to say about stranger
things before I start watching no it's a
long trail and I kinda have to pee so
yeah let's get laid all right roll it
the following trailer only spoils season
1 of stranger things the bad man will
get us if we show you season 2 before
it's on blu-ray that's true that's true
from the streaming service that's a game
of Thrones away from ruling all of
television and directing duo's like
Tarantino if he referenced films you've
actually seen comes the show yet they
sound alike no I don't want to skip it
drove Robin songs awesome trailer this
is John singing love the 80s you love
Steven Spielberg you love most of
Stephen King just The Shining encounter
Stephen King it counts as a Stephen King
adaptations okay I've never seen Maximum
Overdrive but now I really want to yeah
it's it's it's about an evil truck it's
like all the machines turn evil
ultimately but the leader of the evil
machines is a truck with the Green
Goblin face mmm and Emilio Estevez is in
it yeah it's real good that went through
a few iterations that joke first it was
a clip from dreamcatcher or they're
farting yep and it was that's a little
too like it's farts but you may not have
any idea what that's from
yeah and then it was a clip of Emilio
and the Green Goblin and then our
wonderful editors Kevin and TJ found
that clip well there is no shortage of
dumb Stephen King adaptation clips to
choose from you know yeah okay you gotta
watch this continue now you're all grown
up and the real world is fairly business
so escape to a slick vegetable series
you'd watch at double speed if it meant
you could get it into your brain sooner
must revisit childhood escape horrible
present-day pause for a second yeah
because Dan you have a theory on why
stranger things are so popular it's not
that if I remember I do I have a theory
on why because I was a nerd growing up
as I think many of the people watching
stranger things are and I have a theory
that it part of the reason why it's so
popular is that the people that were
nerdy growing up generally were just
nerdy and then you either grew out of it
or you were just ostracized for your
entire minimum high school career and
started working on an Australian I
started going and writing and work on us
trailers later
and showing them who's boss any they're
not watching watching big kid now but I
think that are doing deals damn yeah
they're doing deals crushing it whatever
it is
crushing it and we're analyzing it yeah
but now I have a theory that that one of
these astringent things is so popular is
that it is like a catharsis because here
are these outcasts nerdy ostracized kids
but then they're proven right it's like
everything that they're nerdy about it's
like there are monsters and there is a
friend who has psychic powers who comes
from a secret lab and all the grown-ups
do believe them and and join them and
fight monsters with them and the cool
older kids who used to yell at them are
now their friends and it's like this
thing of like oh wow it would have been
cool if when I was you know playing D&D
or reading comic books if like that had
become the real world and now I'm the
cool kid that gets to do all these
things
yeah and I'm proven right teach me about
hairspray right yeah yeah I'm gonna get
to hang out with the jock who would not
give any of these kids that in the real
world it sees it too I'm literally
telling the police how to do their
investigation out of a Dungeon Master's
guide oh the mind flare well here it's
weaknesses yeah exec spirt I do think
that strange things popularity is
obviously beyond nerdom yeah that's a
second I think for me what I put in
there is I think it is like even though
they're dealing with the apocalypse and
monsters it's still better than 2017 so
people are just like oh yeah oh
childhood no cell phones no internet no
this know that like there's something
calming about literally revisiting sort
of your fantasized version of your own
highly fantasized version of yeah like
middle-american in the 80s yeah this is
slightly before my time but yeah it's
just good it's just good yeah good
characters good story but I do think
there is for the core audience a
particular appeal of just like oh wow
that would have been cool you know and
I would have loved it if the x-men had
or the equivalent of the X minutes shown
up when I was a kid they didn't I just
it wasn't cool and then I rescued
Brandon from them
yeah that your friend nope I think
Brandon might have been his bully
continued visit the idyllic suburb of
Hawkins Indiana a small town where
nobody seems to pay any mind to the
giant high security top-secret lab with
hundreds of employees and Wynnum where
they'll have ghosts mrs. Hawkins tell
Romero full of Goonies we band together
to recreate the cutest version of the
hangover you've ever seen where one
character disappears where is doc
where's well one character is missing T
one character is cool and skeptical and
one character is a dangerous liability
to the rest of the groove she also could
have done a hopper Mike Tyson this is a
this is a Spencer I think you noticed
this right it started just from will
being like we're like he's like we're
trying to do the for kids and he's yeah
guy in the hangover that is only at the
very beginning of the movie then you
never see him again
till the very end you'll see you'll see
we often do this on good things because
these are good and there's a lot of bad
things to say we expand and say what are
some other interesting things yeah so
we're not saying that string of things
is identical to the hangover we are
perhaps in a humorous manner saying some
things that are similar making a
surprising comparison for the sake of
humor
yes let's explain the joke further to
make it even funny
so wait so the hangover is a different
film and medium which different but
similar possibly similar characters okay
we should have like a that's the joke
cue all right let's keep going continue
will may be missing but there's plenty
of other strange things to go around
like Mike's sister trapped in a love
triangle between two haircuts misty Bob
anyone for your son's loss by getting
really into arts and crafts Harbor and
in the second one one's wearing the
whole wall every time I guess that's
welcome
it's Boba Fett look I get it he's
awkward and she didn't deserve to die
but how about the dude at the beginning
who got shot just for helping a lost
child where's the hashtag justice for
Benny huh puss puss do we want to go
deeper into the barb situation we jump
on the barbed train we had some
disagreements about barb I think your
Barb's character why people like barb so
much I mean I get it but I don't approve
of it look no one was forcing her to go
to the no and every moment in time and I
get it she's she doesn't want to lose
her friend but it was coming from a
pretty selfish place it was not what's
best for Nancy what what was best for
Nancy Steve wasn't like those kids were
just drinking beers like they weren't
they weren't killing people they weren't
like shooting heroin they were doing
like the most mild version of teenagers
hanging out on on film they're just
drinking by a pool when their parents
are out of town and she's like you can't
be like this this isn't you like what
having a good time like having a
boyfriend barb was selfish is what I'm
friends Encounter barb
yeah counter barb was that Nancy was not
very comfortable with Steve Harrington's
group of friends she asked barb to go
with her party and specifically
requested that barb not allow her to do
anything that she would be uncomfortable
with so all she was clearly too
comfortable with where she went but she
wasn't being herself and I think if she
had it to do over again that she
wouldn't have done it because this led
to some very uncomfortable consequences
for her so Bob's death yeah like Barnes
death and she got her name spray-painted
on a marquee very bad things these
friends of Steve Harrington's were no
good the friends were no good these were
no good and all barb was trying to do
was be a good friend and what thanks did
she get for that she got shunned and and
eaten off of a diving board but arguably
if she didn't she never would have
enticed the lovely Steve to come save
her life and many others when the
demagoguing came lurking around this is
true yes you know season two actually
sort of landed my my barb feelings in
that you know Dan says hey Nancy you
weren't being yourself but the boys
themselves are no longer being
themselves in season two because they're
they're fighting over girls and you know
something I don't know barb just need to
grow faster I maintain the barb was just
trying to be a good friend
keep her friend out of trouble keep her
friend from growing and experiencing
happiness in her life I disagree look a
lot of parents it was bad news at that
time a lot of people have suggested us
on Twitter you know regularly we'll get
suggestions of like man you guys are
just like film what goes on and your
writers are in the office and I always
disagree with it until the day that you
guys went hard at each other about bar
hard on barb you guys went hard on barb
good 20 to 25 minutes just going well
you know sometimes it was good I just
did barb for it look clear they're doing
something right because they we got 25
minutes worth a conversation about barb
who's in maybe six minutes of screen
time barb barb effect Barbara Barbara
fan oh I should have gone him it's done
pause yes
check justice for Benny huh sued up with
2016's breakout character slash
Halloween costume 11 she's one part
Kerry
one part the kid from boyhood identical
identical its I had to send I showed
Spencer a picture and and and he was
like oh is that a lot I don't know
that's the kid for boy LR Coltrane and
lol are cult I think seller Coltrane and
that was his I think third boyhood hmm
out of seven boyhood ha but yes they it
it's it's there there are other ones
that are they're stunning
they're stunningly it's the shaved head
I think and they just have similar
facial features I'm sure they would
strikingly different now but does his
nose bleed when he moves stuff with his
mind I haven't seen I don't want to
spoil it yeah that's fair and keep gone
boyhood and one part reminder that Eggo
waffles is part of a balanced breakfast
watch as she expands her vocabulary
outside the secret lab Wednesday
Kellogg's discovering the joys of a
Wonder Woman family is marriage to the
murder be my wife oh wow she just
straight-up exploded their brains didn't
G can we just cut back to her doing
something cute again please don't get
caught up with a group of Chicago street
toughs and a standalone season 2 episode
that while providing a much-needed arc
for your character also completely
derail the show's narrative momentum he
wrote just before season to pass down an
alternate dimension that's just like our
own if it were covered in snot ropes and
dandruff it's a dangerous world that can
only be crossed am to budget for sundown
in season to drive or this portal in the
woods or these Christmas lights Adam can
make walk or in the Doty in salt water
in wills not serious Italian courgette
a monster who's either an invisible
unkillable lightning-fast predator or if
the story demands it a slow-moving golem
who gets wrecked by a 16 year old with a
baseball bat
I hope they don't do what aliens did and
replace the big monster with a bunch of
smaller easier to kill versions yeah any
creature imaginable in your mind's eye
and you just seem awkward Emma Gorgon a
lot a bunch of smaller demagoguery yeah
did we say by the way I think we're
gonna get well actually I think John
might have said Demi Gorgon and mo and I
have been called on this myself perhaps
maybe he did I thought in my head I
heard dimming Gorgon if we did say Timmy
Gorgon guess where it's dimma Gorgon I
have been called on that for saying
Debbie Gorgon it is dimma Gorgon how
interesting bear situation yet so what
do they call that I forget what it's
called
there's a word for it anyway variants
the word for what the whole Berenstein
bears a whole there's a name for it yeah
it makes sense alternate universe yeah
in the upside down it's barren and here
it's burned no it's steamed and stains
being stained yeah yeah or it's only if
they if they put that nod in the upside
down it's just a barren yeah moving on
Tim accordion spitballing so hop on the
back pegs and ride along with one of
Netflix's biggest hits that could have
posted by on pure nostalgia but goes the
extra mile by adding a tight story with
a great young cast who better crank out
the next season's fast cuz if you think
the dimming organ is relentless wait
until puberty is on your tail now
clock's ticking Dustin story
birds bikes hugs Slenderman more
nosebleeds than a horned up animate
characters Gio had to explain the face I
don't get it I mean I knew that it
existed but I don't get why they're
nosebleeds when they're turned on Jo
Jill different on that side of the world
the atmosphere but this award from you
we take your craft seriously and
earnestly believe like me that Ramona
Ryder change the world think TJ might
have noticed this black Cydia dead
Loki stealing the show we're all
Patriots in this house sir being able to
talk to Mike's mom I want you to feel
like you can talk to me Nancy
what you can talk to me Joyce if you
need anything
sorry nice conflicted Nancy with a find
out in season two it's staunch
Republican
right now not saying that's good or bad
I just that we kind of found out where
everyone was on the political side and
super into the Red Ranger yeah now that
becomes like stepdad bill intensity yet
hey Billy these shots from et jaws
Halloween I take from the plans to unit
think again a Nightmare on Elm Street
standby me an American Werewolf in
London and et
hammerhead his name is Yoda he can use
the force to move things with his mind
and the only way pop culture knows how
to explain alternate-dimension yes third
time third time in a doorway
he's placed in our stellar trailer took
a higher dimension nostalgic things yeah
you know what's gonna suck when TV shows
get nostalgic for 2017 and show kids
dabbing on a hoverboard like it wasn't
the worst time ever showing yeah kids
aren't gonna think that's the worst time
ever well maybe I don't know my um as
far as our ongoing right situation than
we were explaining why we can't show
clip from season two we had a song a
music video playing there that because
you guys remember what it was named
Danielle some something it's like this
little blonde rapper girl her snipers
form too much even when she's dabbing on
a hoverboard she was like it's like
everyone watches her dab when she rolls
past that's too much swag even I'm a
hoverboard yeah a poorly constructed rap
yeah
Kevin our editor found it we you know
it's there was a fan the name of the the
name of the music video like started
with the word in brackets deleted like
they even had to they even had to say
like by the way we deleted this before
you watch it this is not this was
removed it is an interesting it's kind
of a Friday s type song yeah it's very
early Rebecca Black
yeah I remember what Kevin just emailed
like dab and hoverboard on it chopped up
all right the kids loved it Joe's gonna
track it down
in the meantime maybe oak on Danielle
calm co h n yeah check that one out
what's the video called delete it if
it's called Marilyn Marilyn Monroe yeah
it is something the summer not gonna be
up straight down yeah all right let's do
the deleted scenes and a directing Joe
that sounds like a late 90s techno group
Wow she straight up kills me without a
second thought
but refuses to hurt a cat the wonder
nerds love the show I love that clip
from history the heart of Hawkins the US
government experimented on ladies with
LSD stole their children turned them
into tiny Jean Grey's and use them to
access a crawl space between our world
and a shadow dimension all to listen in
on the Russians really just building
smaller microphones didn't seem easier
promise just a case of nothing wrong
with it but time yeah I guess just for
time there's a long one as the TP ones
usually are and yeah but it's a fair
point they went through a lot of time
and expense to listen in on the Russian
government yep there's other ways then
kidnapping and if you want to know will
tell you yeah after the show trying so
hard not to make political statement
third Flanders mmm I like him yeah we
didn't copper no these didn't even make
it to the video states John bender a
little check absolutely Nancy face hey
oh these are some run different Nancy
face yeah this is her other face I love
the eighties was it squad
gigs have been good we had to send these
earlier because Robert our graphics what
guy when I go much-needed much-needed
holiday yeah that's it
stranger things I missed the window to
JT's booth where you could give us a
thumbs up or a thumbs now I have no way
of knowing what do you think we're
literally talking to a wall brick wall
yeah oh well well yeah that's stranger
things guys you excited for season 3
yeah yeah I like season 2 I'm Eric crank
these things out quick man who do you
think's gonna get hit Dustin no I think
they're all going to age gracefully I
hope so and at the same rate because
it'd be weird if like Mike comes back
it's already like 6 foot 2 or something
yeah if you turned into Billy over the
was a Billy was that the dude's name
Max's brother really we came back babies
Billy and all the kids are still kids
there's already some real creative
camera framing to like make all these
kids look short it's ok cuz they're
taking a year off in the story it's not
like The Walking Dead where it's been
like what like two years since it
started or whatever in coral is like 24
years old they're you know it lost it
the same thing you paint yourself into a
corner when you put a TV show in a
compressed timeline but you cast a kid
because launched like three seasons it's
supposed to be like four months and Walt
is like in high school I mean just any
time you want to cast like a child and
you've got a situation like that just
change the character to an animal
because there's an infinite number of
orange tabby cats and it's fine
sounds unethical for some reason well
they might change but we never will no
but do look into honest trailer
commentaries every Tuesday and a certain
time we will be back next week with we
doing fencing injustice next week right
no no what are we doing what are we oh
yes right all right yeah tangentially
related to dispensation we'll be doing
like okay here's a hint okay
much like next week sighs trailer will
be doing honest trailer commentaries
forever
oh thanks watching guys see you next
week
today's episode is brought to you by
t-mobile switch to America's best
unlimited network
you